donc je vous souhaite la bienvenue et
surtout je vous remercie vivement de
vous êtes rendus disponible pour cette
audition vous êtes d'une certaine
manière à l'origine de la création de
cette commission d'enquête car votre
témoignage dans votre livre intitulé un
silence en 2020 a été le point de départ
d'une immense vague de dénonciation de
violence en tout genre subi par des
jeunes sportifs dans de nombreuses
fédérations comme vous le savez
l'Assemblée nationale a choisi de créer
cette commission d'enquête à la suite de
ces très nombreuses révélations
publiques et de divers scandales
judiciaires ayant très à la gestion de
certaines fédérations nous avons entamé
les travaux de cette commission
d'enquête sur l'identification des
défaillances de fonctionnement au sein
des Fédération Française de sport du
monde sportif et des organismes de
gouvernance du monde sportif le 20
juillet 2023 nos travaux se déclinent
donc autour de trois axes
l'identification des violences physiques
sexuelles ou psychologiques dans le
sport l'identification des
discriminations sex dans le sport et
l'identification des problématiques
liées à la gouvernance financière des
fédérations sportives et des organismes
de gouvernance du monde sportif
bénéficiant d'une délégation de service
public vous êtes bien évidemment
concerné au premier titre puisque vous
êtes la première grande champion
internationale avoir dénoncé des faits
de viol à touchement et harcèlement
moral de la part de votre entraîneur
Monsieur Gilbert lorsque vous aviez
entre 15 et 17 ans dans votre livre vous
avez expliqué dans le détail la manière
dont ces faits se sont produits votre
incapacité à verbaliser ses horreurs à
l'époque avant d'avoir été victime d'une
amnésie traumatique pendant de
nombreuses années
votre témoignage est extrêmement
poignant étant donné la gravité des
sévices auxquelles vous avez été soumise
mais également parce qu'il montre la
solitude dans laquelle vous êtes vous
êtes trouvés à l'époque malgré des
parents et amis très proches
l'irresponsabilité dans laquelle s'est
trouvé votre agresseur du fait de son
aura dans la sphère du patinage
artistique et de l'omerta autour de son
comportement vicieux à l'égard des
jeunes patineuses manifestement bien
connues sont également très choquantes
enfin l'absence de soutien de la
Fédération comme au plus haut niveau de
l'État à l'époque des faits est très
grave
pouvez-vous nous en reparler aujourd'hui
et nous indiquer si les réformes
entreprises au ministère des sports
comme au sein de la fédération depuis
votre témoignage vous paraissent adapté
à la situation vous plaidez aujourd'hui
pour
l'imprescriptibilité des crimes sexuels
sur mineur et la reconnaissance de
l'amnésie traumatique et vous avez créé
une association il y a environ un an la
voix de Sarah pour poursuivre votre
combat dans la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles pouvez-vous nous en
expliquer votre démarche je rappelle que
cette audition est ouverte à la presse
et qu'elle est retransmise en direct sur
le site de l'Assemblée nationale avant
de vous laisser la parole pour répondre
à ses premières questions et d'entamer
nos échanges pendant environ 1h30 je
vous rappelle que l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires imposent aux
personnes entendues par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure après
avoir activé votre micro mais je pense
que ça va de soi
je pense qu'il est activé est-ce que
vous m'entendez très bien je vous
entends oui donc je le jure de dire la
vérité et rien que la vérité je vous
remercie et donc vous avez la parole
oui bonjour à tous et merci de
m'accueillir et merci d'être à
l'initiative de cette de cette enquête
et de ce rendez-vous d'aujourd'hui
il y avait pas mal de questions
effectivement que vous m'aviez que vous
m'aviez posé donc oui effectivement ça
m'a pris 30 ans pour pour parler et pour
essayer de de de
dire ce mot si difficile à dire ce mot
viol mais j'ai enfin j'ai enfin réussi
après 30 ans oui après de nombreuses
séances de psychologie avec Madame
Meryam Salmi puisque j'ai commencé une
psychologie en 2004
et
j'ai évidemment j'ai comme vous l'aviez
signalé j'ai subi une amnésie
traumatique et oubliée pendant beaucoup
beaucoup d'années
ce qui m'a permis de parler en 2019 et
bien c'est d'avoir continué avec ma
psychologue d'avoir aussi beaucoup fait
de méditation de sophro et j'ai essayé
évidemment de parler à plusieurs
reprises mais je n'avais pas été entendu
malheureusement et j'avais une dernière
chance c'était de parler en 2019 et de
et d'écrire ce livre de d'aussi de faire
une enquête avec Emmanuela vernison du
Nouvel Obs pour qu'on puisse retrouver
d'autres d'autres femmes qui auraient
subi la même chose que moi et je ne
pouvais plus supporter l'idée que mon
agresseur soit dans un club de patinage
artistique et qui puisse et ben de
nouveau en fait
reproduire ce qu'il a reproduit sur moi
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai trouvé le
courage et ça m'a pris beaucoup de temps
et beaucoup de courage de parler mais
aujourd'hui quand je vois le résultat
bien je me dis heureusement que je l'ai
fait j'essaie de faire de ce malheur une
force aujourd'hui et
de continuer le combat parce que
dénoncer c'est bien mais continuer le
combat c'est mieux donc je continue le
combat à travers mon association la voix
de Sarah et je continue le combat sur le
terrain en sensibilisant et en
expliquant ma propre histoire
de manière à ce que on puisse et bien
détecter certains comportements
inadaptés ou que certaines victimes
puissent me parler puisque à chaque fois
il y a toujours évidemment
malheureusement
une victime qui qui parle et qui dénonce
donc voilà aujourd'hui bon un petit peu
pour résumer un petit peu tout après il
faut plus rentrer dans le détail par
rapport à vos différentes questions et
voilà et je peux reprendre par rapport à
des questions que vous pouvez reposer
bien sûr
c'était pour faire un résumé d'abord de
ce que j'étais en train d'entreprendre
madame la rapporteur
oui merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté de
témoigner dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête
c'est extrêmement important parce que
comme l'a dit madame la Présidente c'est
vrai que votre livre a été un élément
déclencheur je pense dans le mouvement
sportif de manière générale et ça a
permis de libérer la parole même si
depuis qu'on a commencé les travaux on
se rend bien compte que n'est pas encore
au bout de ce qui pourrait être fait on
en est bien loin et qui reste encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire pour réussir
à avancer sur cette question au sein de
ce moment sportif moi j'ai vraiment
une question parce que dans votre livre
que j'ai eu l'occasion de lire qui m'a
vraiment enfin c'était
très fort comme témoignage et moi ça m'a
beaucoup marquée en tout cas de lire ce
témoignage et le cheminement finalement
qu'il a fallu pour que vous puissiez
coucher par écrit ce que vous avez pu
vivre dans votre parcours de sportif ce
qui m'a beaucoup marqué c'est
le fait que vous vous racontiez
finalement que beaucoup de personnes
étaient au courant de ce qu'il se
passait
qu'il était identifié finalement comme
un prédateur y compris d'ailleurs je
crois un professeur qui ne laissait pas
sa fille dormir dans le dortoir parce
qu'il savait et
moi j'aimerais vraiment que vous
reveniez peut-être sur cela parce que
l'objectif de cette commission vraiment
et de travailler sur justement les
défaillances au sein des fédérations ou
des clubs pour faire en sorte d'abord de
briser l'omerta bien sûr mais de faire
en sorte qu'il n'y ait plus d'impunité
que tout le monde puisse témoigner de
choses qui ne devraient pas se passer et
donc je trouve que ça serait intéressant
justement que vous puissiez revenir sur
cette partie de votre témoignage je vous
remercie
oui effectivement
j'en avais parlé notamment au président
de mon club section artistique parce
qu'il y a plusieurs présidents souvent
dans les clubs il y a le président du
club hockey sur glace et artistique je
n'avais parlé j'étais allé chez lui avec
mon oncle parce que je voulais pas
évidemment y aller toute seule parce que
c'est déjà horrible de parler de toutes
ces choses là mais malheureusement je
n'avais pas été entendu c'est à dire que
ce que j'avais dit c'était comme si
je parlais d'un simple mâle de jambes ou
de cuisses ou de genou il m'avait
simplement répondu bah écoute va déposer
plainte et puis en gros on en reparlera
donc j'avais été très gentiment
remercier alors que je lui ai dit que
cet entraîneur était dangereux qui
m'était arrivé ce qui m'est arrivé à
l'âge de 15 ans et que il fallait
essayer de l'éloigner de ce club
donc ça je n'avais pas été effectivement
entendu
d'autre part j'en avais parlé à l'époque
encore une fois au ministère et on
m'avait dit qu'il y avait un dossier
mais qui valait mieux fermer les yeux et
quelques années plus tard j'ai
effectivement appris qu'un professeur
papa d'élèves
qui connaissait très bien mon agresseur
effectivement
connaissait le problème et qui savait
qu'il était dangereux c'est pour ça que
sa fille n'était pas dans les dortoirs
et qu'elle dormait avec lui donc c'est
quand même des personnes qui étaient qui
étaient complices d'un certain d'un
certain système évidemment et moi à
l'époque bon bah évidemment j'ai pas
réussi à déporter
à apporter plein de comme je disais dans
le livre j'ai pas réussi j'étais à la
police et je suis redescendu parce que
j'y arrivais pas et donc tant qu'il n'y
avait pas entre guillemets une
procédure officielle et bien et bien
tout le monde se serrait les coudes pour
pas que ça se sache et pour que tout le
monde continue sa petite vie tranquille
et au sein de la fédération et au sein
de certains clubs malheureusement
justement suite à au signalement que
vous avez fait donc on vous a indiqué
qu'il y avait une enquête en tout cas un
dossier au niveau du ministère est-ce
que vous avez pu en savoir un peu plus
sur ce dossier et des faits qui étaient
peut-être reprochés dans le cadre de ce
dossier s'il y avait vraiment quels
étaient les éléments et deuxième chose
est-ce que vous savez si
suite à vos révélations si les personnes
qui étaient informées à l'époque et qui
n'ont pas réagi en tout cas qui n'ont
pas déclenché d'enquête qui ne vous ont
pas accompagné ce que vous savez s'ils
ont été inquiétés par la justice ou par
une procédure administrative au sein de
la fédération
alors au niveau du dossier
genre
je savais enfin j'ai su ce qu'il en
était mais quelques années après c'est à
dire que on nous on nous disait toujours
et c'est Marie Georges buffet qui avait
en fait
éloigné Gilbert de la fédération et
qu'il l'avait suspendu pendant 6 mois et
il avait été réintégré à la Fédération
grâce à la Fédération française des
sports de glace au niveau de la
Fédération française et des notamment
des compétitions internationales junior
il avait réété intégré ce dossier je
n'ai jamais pu l'avoir en main mais je
sais que
avec l'enquête qui avait été
prise en charge par par Emmanuel anison
le dossier aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et peut être disponible après moi je
n'ai pas eu accès à ce dossier mais tout
est écrit dans ce dossier qui peut être
qui peut être lu aujourd'hui en tout cas
les personnes concernées à l'époque je
crois que elles n'ont pas été inquiétées
malheureusement et je ne sais pas si
elles ont elles ont eu aussi
une enquête administrative je ne sais
pas je crois aussi que cette personne
qui m'avait reçu
qui n'est autre que Monsieur Stéphane
clou ancien président donc de artistique
et de nouveau je crois au club des
Français Volants et de nouveaux à la
présidence ou dans le club en tout cas
je n'ai pas la vérification mais en tout
cas il est il est voilà il est toujours
présent il est revenu en tout cas tant
qu'à monsieur
le monsieur professeur aussi de
mathématiques qui étaient au sein des
Français Volants je ne sais pas s'il
avait été entendu par rapport à par
rapport à ça je ne sais pas
vous dites que vous avez essayé de
parler parce que ça soit la Fédération
au ministère que vous avez trouvé
porte-close et qu'on vous demandait donc
de pas trop évoquer cette affaire que
votre livre était la dernière chance
pour vous exprimer j'ai envie de vous
poser la question est-ce que vous
considérez que la situation à la changer
ce que les victimes aujourd'hui elles
peuvent trouver davantage la possibilité
de s'exprimer est-ce qu'elles sont
suffisamment entendues que ce soit déjà
dans votre fédération sport de glace ou
dans d'autres fédérations parce que
j'imagine que vous côtoyez aussi
toujours des sportifs de haut niveau qui
s'expriment vous sachant plutôt à
l'écoute
bien sûr oui alors on avance
effectivement on a 30 ans de retard moi
je suis très proche effectivement du
ministère des Sports et de Madame la
Ministre avec cette cette structure
signale sport qui est aussi dans mon
association présente sur mon site
internet et quand on clique dessus on
peut directement
signaler
des dénoncer donc ça c'est directement
en lien avec avec la voix de Sarah je
suis de près tout tous les tous les
sportifs qui qui auraient dénoncé le
nombre de sportifs et à plus de 900
sportifs aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que
souvent suite à mon à mon livre et mon
témoignage ils disent puisque ça ravis
de vol à parler bah nous on doit être
capable de parler voilà on dénonce
aujourd'hui donc oui c'est pris en main
et heureusement Roxana ma racine à nous
l'ancienne ministre a vraiment pris ça à
bras le corps et je la remercie
aujourd'hui parce que elle a elle a eu
la force et l'audace de
me suivre à 100%
ça n'avait pas été le cas
malheureusement auparavant et Madame la
Ministre aujourd'hui madame Amélie ouai
à Castera ou d'Era Castera pardon aussi
et derrière derrière tout ça avec cette
cellule de crise est très très présente
contre les violences sexuelles dans le
sport
avec un code d'honorabilité aussi qui a
été mis en place donc oui bien sûr qu'on
avance et je pense que maintenant les
victimes ont moins peur de parler
qu'elles
osent plus et que les détracteurs aussi
du coup
se sente moins en sécurité c'est ce que
je pense aujourd'hui maintenant il faut
continuer le combat continuer cette
sensibilisation aller sur le terrain et
c'est pour ça que avec la voix de Sarah
on a on a organisé beaucoup de
conférences on est allés sur sur les des
mouvements sportifs avec une exposition
qui s'appelle cri d'alerte une
exposition de photographie qui ont été
originales c'est ce sont des œuvres
originales qui ont été montées avec un
avec un réalisateur pour
de manière poétique et artistique en
fait sensibiliser d'une autre façon et
on est très très présent sur le terrain
alors on voudrait l'être plus mais
malheureusement il manque de l'argent et
il manque des salaires pour être
partout et multitâche mais à un moment
donné je peux pas me malheureusement me
couper en deux donc j'essaie avec ma
directrice de la voix de Sarah va être
présente et puis de sensibiliser au
maximum je pense que les choses bien sûr
ont été prises en main je me bats encore
au quotidien et on lâchera rien c'est ce
qu'on a dit avec Madame la Ministre des
Sports on lâchera vraiment rien pour
continuer le combat et que les victimes
les plus peur de dénoncer
j'ai beaucoup travaillé aussi avec avec
le Sénat sur une loi la loi Sarah Bitbol
qui a été élu à 100% auprès du Sénat et
qui j'espère va pouvoir être présente à
la sangle nationale sur le code d'une
aurabilité en fait dans les clubs parce
qu'on s'est aperçu que les clubs ne
remontaient pas en fait l'information
l'information sur les casiers
judiciaires et donc on a beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus pour que en fait le
président de chaque club soit aussi en
charge de remonter les informations à
chaque fédération et qu'il est
poursuivialement s'il ne l'a pas fait ça
cette loi vient d'être vient d'être
adoptée au mois de au mois de juin le 15
juin et on est en train de travailler
avec les sénateurs pour qu'elle puisse
être validée à l'Assemblée nationale
d'ici quelques mois donc voilà on est
toujours enfin moi je suis toujours
vraiment sur dans mon combat parce que
je fais de ce malheur une force
aujourd'hui pour pour aider le sport mon
sport encore plus mon sport que j'aime
tant parce que je suis passionné je suis
entraîneur de patinage artistique j'ai
ma carte professionnelle j'ai le brevet
d'état premier degré et voilà il a
fédération est venue vers moi au mois de
juin ma propre Fédération de patinage
artistique effectivement je n'y croyais
pas je n'y croyais plus mais elle est
venue vers moi la présidente de la
Fédération ainsi que le directeur
technique national pour que je travaille
avec eux au sein du comité éthique et je
suis rentrée donc dans le comité éthique
pour
poursuivre mon combat regarder les
dossiers
aller sur le terrain avec en tant que
Fédération française des sports de glace
donc ils ont pris aussi les choses en
main mais très récemment c'est à dire
que ça date du mois de juin
si vous le permettez je vais vous
reposer la question je voulais savoir si
vous receviez des témoignages
aujourd'hui récemment ces dernières
semaines ou mois de sportifs agressé
dans leur centre que ça soit l'INSEP ou
ailleurs auprès de leur coach si vous
avez puisque vous avez brisé l'omerta je
me dis que peut-être qu'on a tendance à
venir vous contacter notamment via votre
association mais ce que vous recevez
aujourd'hui toujours des témoignages
ou des appels au secours
oui bien sûr j'en reçois j'en reçois
toujours dans le domaine du sport et pas
que mais dans le domaine du sport oui
pas plus tard qu'il y a quelques jours
une patineuse malheureusement c'était
dans le patinage et j'ai pris bien sûr
le dossier en main et de remonter auprès
de la Fédération française des sports de
glace au niveau du comité éthique et
nous allons nous en occuper donc oui je
reçois encore des témoignages alors qui
peuvent être vraiment alors évidemment
moi je suis plus spécifique au sport
mais je ne je ne refuse jamais une une
victime qui veut me parler parce que
c'est vrai que quand on a été victime on
a une manière de recevoir la parole qui
est peut-être différente il y a une
confiance qui s'instaure et il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui arrivent à me
parler alors qu'elles ont jamais parlé
auparavant et j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
aidé beaucoup de personnes
notamment aussi pendant cette tournée de
l'idée on aille sous où j'ai où j'ai
travaillé sur un message d' pour toutes
les victimes avec des élastiques dans
lequel j'étais bloquée et que j'essayais
de sortir de ces élastiques et il y a
beaucoup de personnes victimes qui sont
venues me voir à la pause je faisais une
séance de dédicace et j'avais aussi des
des panneaux de mon association la voix
de Sarah crie d'alerte qui était
derrière moi et qui venait me parler en
me disant merci grâce à vous je vais
mieux grâce à vous j'ai brisé le silence
grâce à vous je suis allée au
commissariat ou grâce à vous j'ai parlé
à mon mari et ça j'ai aussi aidé
beaucoup de monde à travers ce ce
spectacle vous voyez comme quand on peut
aussi sensibiliser d'une autre façon le
public et j'ai sensibilisé plus de 2000
personnes à raison de deux spectacles
par jour sur 84 spectacles donc 200000
personnes ont été sensibilisés
je suis désolé d'insister à nouveau mais
je reviens sur les témoignages que vous
recevez je veux savoir dans quel
contexte vous recevez des témoignages
que vous expriment les sportifs
concernés sont des hommes des femmes et
donc dans quel contexte ce produit
l'agression c'est ce qui m'intéresse
aujourd'hui
d'accord alors les
les agressions là sur le dernier enfin
le pour citer un dernier message que
j'ai reçu c'était des violences
psychologiques sur la glace
cette jeune femme n'est pas rentrée dans
les détails pour le moment à l'écrit
parce que je pense qu'elle était pas
prête mais elle m'a fait part de
plusieurs choses mais elle voulait me
voir pour m'en parler et pas plus tard
qu'hier soir j'ai reçu un
texto et on doit s'en parler de vive
voix donc violence psychologique des
entraîneurs je crois qu'il n'avaient pas
le brevet d'état et qui était sur la
glace et qui ça n'était pas normal
et des choses plus graves
dont elle n'a pas pu écrire pour le
moment et que je dois voilà que je dois
élucider que je dois avoir avec elle
directement
voilà en général c'est violence
psychologique et ça peut être violent
évidemment plus grave des violences
comme moi j'ai comme moi j'ai pu subir
mais souvent elle elle commence par un
écrit qui est un petit peu plus
qui est un peu plus léger pour rentrer
dans des détails un petit peu plus tard
quand on fait des visios quand on se
voit etc etc c'est toujours difficile je
pense de parler aux éléments directement
et des sportifs de haut niveau ou des
sportifs sports de glace au sein d'un
club d'une association
sportive de haut niveau en général
ici signal directement ministère sur
signal sur signal sport il y en a
énormément et qui cite mon nom moi sur
les dernières les dernières victimes sur
la voix de Sarah c'était plus dans le
domaine de mon de mon sport
ou après le ministère parfois me redonne
des dossiers pour aller parler aussi aux
victimes directement parce que c'est
vrai qu'une ancienne malheureusement
athlète et victime peut plus libérer la
parole de quelqu'un
voilà et puis on n'est pas non plus une
association encore très connue donc je
sais que colosse au pied d'argile qui
travaille depuis plus longtemps que moi
doit recevoir plus peut-être de
témoignages que moi dans le domaine du
sport puisqu'on est maintenant plusieurs
associations à travailler
avant de laisser la question à ma
collègue Claudia Rouault je voulais
juste savoir si vous étiez accompagné
d'une psychologue au sein de votre
association
alors oui on a on a une
psychiatre d'ailleurs au sein de mon
association mais on n'est pas assez
nombreux mais il y a une autre
association qui va nous aider et qui qui
travaille
depuis quelques temps maintenant avec
des victimes et qui est son mari et
femme donc il y a un homme et une femme
et il va nous rejoindre aussi au niveau
de l'association
je vais laisser la parole à Madame la
rapporteur
oui je vais revenir un tout petit peu en
arrière du coup parce que tout à l'heure
on a auditionné des sportifs en
athlétisme qui nous ont fait part elles
aussi du fait qu'elle recevait un corps
pas mal de témoignages de victimes
aujourd'hui qui sont dans à l'inseep ou
au sein de la fédération d'athlétisme
mais elle nous indiquait que
d'après les témoignages les fédérations
sont au courant mais qu'elles ne brise
pas justement
le silence ou en tout cas qu'il n'y a
pas de remontée ni d'enquête
administrative ni auprès de la cellule
du ministère étant donné qu'on est à
moins d'un an des Jeux Olympiques et que
les médailles comptent plus que tout
donc on a quand même le sentiment d'un
côté que les choses on a pris conscience
peut-être de ce qui n'allait pas mais
est-ce que vous diriez que dans les
faits aujourd'hui on a avancé au point
qu'on puisse justement ne plus avoir à
traiter ce genre de situation
que ce soit d'ailleurs au sein de cette
fédération d'athlétisme pour laquelle
visiblement
il y a eu des avancées mais pas
tellement et peut-être plus vous au
niveau de la Fédération que vous
connaissez est-ce que vous estimez
aujourd'hui
que les choses ont enfin dans le bon
sens oui vous l'avez dit mais peut-être
qu'il reste encore beaucoup de choses à
faire et j'aimerais plus vous entendre
là dessus
oui concernant ma fédération en avance
et il y a encore effectivement beaucoup
de beaucoup de choses à faire
au niveau de toutes les autres
fédérations je ne peux pas
en parler directement puisque j'ai pas
eu à faire à part la Fédération
Française de Tennis j'ai rencontré le
président et j'ai été allé
lors d'un colloque
avec l'association
rebond et Isabelle Demongeot dont je
suis assez proche maintenant et le
président m'avait parlé en me disant
bravo pour ce que tu as fait tu as brisé
le silence nous on est là en tant que
fédération pour vraiment continuer dans
le bon sens et ne plus jamais que ça
arrive et on va et on va on va être
vraiment très très vigilant sur sur les
entraîneurs le mode d'entraînement etc
donc lui en tout cas je l'ai rencontré
je sais que je peux dire que avec aussi
l'association
d'Isabelle de Mongeot et de sa collègue
ils avancent dans le bon sens
concernant les autres fédérations je
pense qu'il y a toujours malheureusement
un petit peu d'omerta et que et qu'on
est encore loin je pense d'un d'un
résultat et de d'un travail en
profondeur parce qu'il y a trop de il y
a trop de clubs aussi il y a trop il y a
beaucoup d'athlètes il y a beaucoup de
donc il faudrait démultiplier les
associations il faudrait je pense que
dans chaque fédération il y a une
association affiliée et que cette
association aille sur le terrain et ça
c'est pas le cas mais alors dans le
tennis c'est le cas puisqu'on les
appelle de montjo dans le patinage
artistique il y a Sarah big bol et la
voix de Sarah maintenant donc on est on
va être affilié à la Fédération et on va
travailler avec eux et aller sur le
terrain mais je pense que chaque
association dans chaque fédération
devrait devrait s'en occuper de manière
plus profonde je pense qu'on n'est pas
assez nombreux après je pense que
c'est c'est un bon
démarrage je pense que les fédérations
aussi ont peur par rapport à tout ce qui
ce qu'on a entendu depuis 2019 et depuis
la la sortie de mon livre et qui sont
plus vigilants
après effectivement on est à moins d'un
an des Jeux Olympiques il y a peut-être
des choses qui sont malheureusement
passées de côté pour les résultats
sportifs et ça c'est c'est inadmissible
c'est inadmissible
dans votre livre vous dites que vous
étiez très proche de vos parents
particulièrement avec votre maman et
pourtant
les parents n'ont rien vu vos parents
n'ont rien vu et c'est souvent
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'exprime les
victimes il y a une méconnaissance et en
même temps un manque de communication
entre les dirigeants sportifs et les
parents
comment
oui c'est à l'époque ce qui s'est passé
je le décris très bien dans le livre
c'est que mon entraîneur mon agresseur a
acheté plus ou enfin acheter mes parents
c'est à dire qu'il les a mis en
confiance il venaient dîner à la maison
voilà il y a toute une confiance qui
s'est instaurée et je pense que les
parents dans ce cas là ils seront ils
peuvent pas penser au pire en fait on se
dit ma fille elle part s'entraîner il a
l'air il a l'air encore une fois
de prendre son travail à coeur et la
garde un petit peu plus sur la glace il
est venu dîner à la maison il est encore
perdu du temps on a parlé des futurs
compétitions donc il a vraiment mis
malheureusement mes parents dans la
poche ce qui fait que c'est encore plus
facile d'attraper sa proie et aussi pour
moi encore plus difficile de parler de
ce qui m'arrive parce que cet entraîneur
est et vénéré plus ou moins de mes
parents en fait quelque part
et il faisait
dans ce club il disait le jour et la
nuit c'est-à-dire c'était le grand
patron de tout il avait les clés de
toutes les portes il entraînait en même
temps il dirigeait manager et en même
temps il était très bien avec l'ancienne
Fédération française des sports de glace
donc tout était je pense qui calculait y
calculé à chaque fois ce qu'il faisait
et je pense évidemment je n'étais pas la
seule puisque ça on en est sûr
maintenant et c'était un je pense que
c'était sonitmotiv c'était ça d'aller
vers les parents et de les acheter et de
se retrouver en famille quelque part
oui tout à fait ce matin nous
auditionions angélique Cauchy
une sportive donc à la Fédération de
tennis et qui nous a témoigné aussi ce
même parcours ce même engrenage
je voudrais savoir si vous avez des
propositions à nous faire
connaissant maintenant en plus de par
votre parcours le contexte de
l'intérieur si vous vous pouviez vous
vous livrez en même temps les raisons et
comment s'en sortir aujourd'hui
quel serait les propositions à nous
faire
je pense que l'idée aussi que Madame
Salmi donc ma psychologue aimait et puis
que plusieurs sportifs dont
madame gaucho c'est ça ce matin j'ai
également écouté quelques quelques
minutes de conversation je pense
qu'effectivement isolé un athlète avec
un entraîneur maintenant ça devient un
petit peu pas dangereux mais que il
faudrait qu'il y ait un double
entraîneur en fait qui est un homme et
une femme à chaque fois alors oui ça
demande plus d'argent et et
que ça implique plus d'entraîneurs oui
mais je pense que ce serait une
protection à avoir d'avoir à chaque fois
un double entraîneur à la fois en
compétition à la fois en réunion à la
fois voilà en déplacement il y a il y a
toujours voilà un homme et une femme
je pense que ça pourrait protéger
certains en tout cas l'athlète et les
prédateurs supposés
Claudia Rouault vous avez une question
oui merci voilà je à vous entendre alors
on a entendu il y a rebond la voix de
Sarah signal sport nous avons auditionné
juste avant deux jeunes athlètes
de la fédération de l'athlétisme qui ont
été longtemps à l'INSEP et qui ne
connaissait pas signal sport il
semblerait que ils en fassent pas du
tout la promotion la communication
donc est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous le saviez parce que
c'est quand même chez les athlètes de
haut niveau qui a le plus de violence
qu'elle soit sexuelle ou autre et c'est
quand même très étonnant que il y a pas
de communication à l'INSEP et
la multiplication de ces associations
qui se créent est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas à un moment donné que ça pourrait
faire perdre un peu en fait diluer
dilué en fait remonter des personnes qui
souhaitent exprimer quelque chose et
puis que finalement ça je pars
réellement ce qui se passe dans les
fédérations et le droit le troisième
point que faut-il faire à l'intérieur
des fédérations pour justement que les
paroles puissent alors sans parler
évidemment de pression qu'on pourrait
faire pour que les fédérations proposent
à la tête violée de porter plainte
puisque je pense que ça c'est le Béaba
mais dans la constitution des
fédérations ou est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose à faire justement pour que ces
athlètes puissent avoir la possibilité
de s'exprimer
alors dans l'ordre première question à
l'INSEP c'est ça le signal sport n'est
pas n'a pas été indiqué et bien vous
faites bien le dire puisque
je ne le savais pas j'ai mon exposition
était présente avec un numéro d'appel le
qui qui fait partie d'une des photos le
signal sport effectivement doit être
véhiculé à l'INSEP de façon évidemment
il faut le il faut il faut qu'il soit il
faut qu'il soit présent et ça il faut en
parler directement voilà la direction et
je peux effectivement faire remonter
l'information signal sport c'est
peut-être pas assez connu effectivement
ça vient pas du ministère puisque sur le
sur le site du ministère au signal sport
est lié il y est en grand et on peut
cliquer pour pour dénoncer et puis
parler du graph problème ou
psychologique ou sexuel qui nous arrive
mais je pense que c'est aux fédérations
et en fait de l'indiquer peut-être que
les clubs ne sont pas au courant non
plus du signal sport ou ne sont pas
assez en place là dessus sur leur site
internet et lors de réunions ne
préviennent pas assez les athlètes de ce
de ce signal en fait donc là il y a
effectivement un vet de molle là-dessus
il va falloir voir avec les différentes
fédérations et tous les clubs pour que
les signal sports soient beaucoup plus
instaurés et qui que ça devienne
automatique en fait
pour la première question la deuxième
sur les différentes associations je
pense que les différentes associations
ne proposent pas la même chose rebond
c'est aussi beaucoup sur la réparation
et les conférences coloss au pied
d'argile c'était des années qui sont
présents avec je crois plus de 40
salariés qui font un travail énorme sur
le terrain et qui sont qui sont au
niveau international aussi très bien
placés qui font un travail super et
différents et la voix de Sarah avec son
exposition et aller sur le terrain à la
fois dans les institutions sportives
les hôpitaux aussi parce que j'ai fait
aussi quelques hôpitaux
on travaille aussi dans les territoires
ultra marins les clubs sportifs et
municipalités il y a pas assez de entre
guillemets de travail pour tout le monde
donc c'est bien qu'il y ait plusieurs
associations et le ministère avait aussi
envisagé plusieurs associations parce
que ils étaient pas assez nombreux donc
ça non c'est pas du tout
un point négatif bien au contraire je
pense que c'est un point positif
voilà et troisième question je me
souviens plus
que faut-il faire dans les fédérations
donc soit dans la constitution des
fédérations ou apporter des personnes
qui pourraient être référentes enfin il
y a sûrement quelque chose à faire au
niveau des fédérations parce que ce
qu'on a entendu depuis ce matin c'est
quand même pas très enfin c'est pas très
glorieux
je pense que dans chaque fédération
effectivement
il faut qu'ils imposent un référent un
référent éthique et puis des référents
éthiques dans chaque club et qui
remontent les informations et que le
président en fait du club c'est ce que
j'ai dit sur la la loi aussi
qu'on a travaillé qui est sorti au mois
de juin que chaque président en fait
remonte les informations nécessaires au
niveau des casiers judiciaires et au
niveau des bénévoles des éducateurs et
de tout le monde au sein du club avec
des avec des réunions et qui imposent un
petit peu plus avec ce code nonorabilité
une convention pour aussi que les
détracteurs ou les les
malheureuses
les entraîneurs qui auraient des
comportements inappropriés sans que il
va pas falloir
ne pas être à la hauteur ou avoir des
comportements qui ne vont pas parce que
ça va remonter directement à la
Fédération et le et là le casier
judiciaire sera en place donc je pense
que c'est vraiment un référent et le
président de chaque club et il y a
énormément de clubs en France qui doit
prendre en charge cette situation là
pour le remonter à sa propre fédération
en fait et qui remonte ensuite au
ministère parce qu'on a le ministère on
a les fédérations et on a les clubs donc
ça passe par plusieurs
stades vous voyez donc il y a un moment
donné si le président du club ne fait
pas son travail on va passer à côté
peut-être de quelque chose de grave et
important que la fédération ne sera pas
et que le ministère ne sera pas non plus
oui alors moi j'avais une question parce
que on parle beaucoup depuis ce matin
des fédérations des clubs et donc aussi
des dirigeants mais ce qu'on a rappelé
au début de la commission d'enquête
c'est qu'on est dans le cadre d'une
délégation de service public et dans ce
cadre-là il y a des agents du ministère
qui sont mises à disposition aussi de
ces fédérations je pense au DTN ou à
d'autres personnes et c'est très étrange
parce que depuis le début des auditions
on en a jamais parlé comme si finalement
il n'était pas là il n'était pas présent
qu'il n'avait aucun rôle à jouer donc
moi j'aimerais vraiment vous entendre là
dessus est-ce que vous ne pensez pas à
un moment que le ministère des Sports
au-delà de la cellule qui a été mise en
place mais par le biais aussi des
personnes qui sont mises à disposition
de ces fédérations n'a pas un rôle à
jouer dans le dispositif pour éviter
justement que qu'il y ait toujours ses
défaillances au sein des fédérations
oui s'ils ont effectivement le ministère
la possibilité de mettre en place ceci
au sein ces personnes là au sein au sein
des clubs c'est un avantage et c'est
quelque chose de positif moi de mon côté
par rapport à l'association et mes
alertes et les spectacles tout ce que
j'ai fait j'ai effectivement je n'ai pas
soulevé cette thématique là mais si le
ministère peut mettre en place ça bien
sûr qu'il faut le faire bien sûr oui oui
et peut-être que c'est pas suffisant
vous avez récemment vécu aux États-Unis
est-ce que vous avez des bonnes
pratiques à nous rapporter de vos
expériences là-bas
oui il y a une notamment une en fait une
convention
qui est signée
c'est une association
qui fait ça et je l'ai d'ailleurs je
l'avais mise de côté je l'avais je
l'avais traduite en français c'est en
anglais c'est une convention en fait
d'une trentaine quarantaine pas de pages
qui indique en fait ce que l'entraîneur
a le droit de faire et ne pas faire
qui est très strict très sévère par
exemple à un entraîneur n'a pas le droit
de prendre la route avec un mineur par
exemple ce qui n'est pas c'est pas dans
les règlements français par exemple ça
moi j'ai pris la voiture à l'époque avec
mon entraîneur il se passait ce qui se
passait et on l'a vu sur d'autres
victimes malheureusement et je pense que
cette convention là devrait être
effectivement
écrite et qu'on devrait la qu'on devrait
la copier pour que les fédérations
signent avec ce protocole là et que si
ce protocole n'est pas n'est pas
respecté et bien il y aura des sanctions
par exemple si demain si j'avais conduit
pardon récemment avec une avec une
mineure et qu'un entraîneur ou qu'une
personne me voit aux États-Unis faire ça
ça remonte directement à cette cette
association avec cette convention qui
remonte à la Fédération américaine et
qui tout de suite met un blâme en disant
vous avez un premier un premier blâme
merci de ne pas reproduire ce que vous
avez fait et au bout de blâme
l'entraîneur il entraîne plus c'est à
dire qu'il y a pas de demi-mesure
c'est une convention qu'on pourrait
copier je pense
alors justement au sujet de cette
convention que vous évoquiez est-ce
qu'il s'agit d'une convention nationale
fédérale comme elle est suivie par qui
peut-être
un peu plus de précision
ouais je il faut que je la retrouve
parce que je l'avais je l'avais dans mon
dans mon ordinateur il faut que je la
retrouve c'est une
c'est une convention en tout cas qui est
automatiquement signée par la Fédération
c'est à dire que
chaque club est obligé de faire en sorte
de de la signer et de et de bien sûr de
de faire attention à ce règlement
interne en fait mais ça je peux de
nouveau regarder me renseigner et vous
et vous faire parvenir ces documents dès
que je les aurai retrouvés parce que je
ne les ai pas sous les yeux là je me
souviens plus du nom exact je pourrais
dire une bêtise mais je peux le
retrouver sans problème et vous faire
part de ce règlement
en anglais qu'on peut traduire en
français je sais pas si je l'ai gardé en
français faut que je regarde dans mes
dans mes emails
très bien pour nous les envoyer par mail
je vous remercie de recommandation qui
vont de Berg qui reviennent souvent dans
vos propos la première concerne
l'imprescriptibilité des crimes sexuels
sur mineur et la seconde concerne la
reconnaissance de l'amnésie traumatique
qui est la perte de mémoire que
certaines victimes subissent après une
telle violence vous défendez la
combinaison de ces deux mesures vous
dites parce que malheureusement on ne se
souvient pas toujours de ce qui s'est
passé et quand on s'en souvient parfois
il est trop tard avec cette prescription
pourriez-vous développer s'il vous plaît
oui et bien
ça a été mon cas mais comme ça a été le
cas de beaucoup beaucoup de victimes ou
effectivement on oublie moi ça s'est
passé à l'âge de 15 ans et le c'est ce
qu'on m'a expliqué après parce que moi
je comprenais pas quand c'est revenu en
fait j'avais l'impression que j'avais
vécu un cauchemar c'était peut-être un
rêve parce que c'était vrai pas vrai et
après les psychologues et les
psychiatres nous expliquent que cette
amnésie traumatique en fait c'est pour
c'est pour protéger l'enfant le cerveau
mais ça de côté pour protéger l'enfant
de quelque chose de très grave donc il
souffre trop ça c'est méconnu ça devient
un peu plus maintenant évidemment on en
parle depuis depuis trois quatre ans on
en parle plus mais c'était méconnu du
grand public et c'est vrai quand on dit
non mais attends ça fait 30 ans pourquoi
d'un coup elle parle de ça et on nous
croyait pas aussi quelque part on
croyait pas les victimes parce qu'on en
parle 30 ans après donc c'est vrai que
l'amnésie traumatique si elle peut être
reconnue dans la loi ça permett aussi à
certaines victimes
lorsqu'elles témoignent d'être cru
d'être cru aussi parce que cette amnésie
est reconnue vous voyez parce que c'est
vrai que où sont les preuves en fait ça
fait 30 ans elles sont où les preuves si
c'est pas un prédateur qui a plusieurs
victimes et que toutes les victimes vont
parler ensemble c'est compliqué aussi de
croire entre guillemets la victime donc
si cette amnésie traumatique elle figure
elle figure dans la loi on comprendra
pourquoi cette personne et cette victime
parle 30 ans après bah parce que le
cerveau s'est protégé de quelque chose
de très grave a mis ça de côté pour
pouvoir vivre normalement mais un jour
effectivement bah ça ça revient ça peut
être un mariage un deuil
un enfant enfin une naissance une
grossesse voilà ça revient et puis ça
nous revient comme une bombe atomique
effectivement
et c'est terrible donc ça ça serait ça
serait effectivement quelque chose de
très bien après là la prescription oui
maintenant elle a été étendue et ça nous
permet d'avoir encore plus de temps mais
si on a l'impression que des crimes
sexuelles sur mineur ça permettrait à ce
que on puisse pas on n'est pas de date
en fait de date limite et puis si 40 ans
après on se on se souvient et bien au
moins on est on peut on peut porter on
peut porter plainte et puis on peut et
puis on peut se reconstruire peut-être
que c'est plus facile aussi de se
reconstruire quand on n'a portait
plainte et que on est cru et que il peut
y avoir un procès alors on sait très
bien que si cette loi peut passer un
jour et moi je me bats évidemment pour
qu'elle passe elle sera pas rétroactive
donc pour mon cas par exemple et
d'autres cas malheureusement c'est trop
tard mais pour les autres pour les
jeunes pour nos enfants pour les enfants
de nos enfants pour les protéger
ça serait extraordinaire puisqu'elle
existe dans les autres pays au
Luxembourg
à Los Angeles aussi voilà elle existe et
elle a été elle a été votée aussi
récemment et je pense que ça pourrait
être un grand pas aussi pour la France
de de d'avoir cette imprécité des crimes
sexuels sur mineur
alors j'ai une question concernant la
Fédération française des sports de glace
donc un rapport de l'inspection générale
de l'éducation du sport et de la
recherche de juin 2023 portant sur la
dite fédération pointe des pratiques
très contestables un fonctionnement
fédéral marqué par l'omniprésence
d'anciens dirigeants ou encore des
élections influencées quel regard
portez-vous sur les changements entamés
depuis la publication de ce rapport
c'était il y a pas si longtemps que ça
et selon vous y a-t-il des points de
vigilance particulière à garder à
l'esprit concernant justement la
direction de cette fédération des sports
de glace
oui alors on est c'est vrai qu'on était
inquiet pour cette fédération française
des sports de glace qui qui a pris
qui a pris beaucoup son contre son image
évidemment en 2019 avec mon témoignage
et à un moment donné ça a été la double
peine puisque moi derrière on m'a encore
plus malheureusement fermé fermer les
portes et certains clubs ne voulaient
pas entendre parler de moi pas parce que
j'avais dit la vérité que j'étais sans
doute dangereuse dangereuse pour pour la
suite je pense qu'il faut évidemment
rester très vigilant le
petit à petit depuis que la nouvelle
présidente est en place il y a des il y
a beaucoup de personnes qui ont été
écartées c'était des personnes je pense
qui qui étaient pas bienveillante et pas
pas complètement transparente voilà
vis-à-vis des sportifs et de et de la
Fédération
ils ont commencé évidemment à écarter
beaucoup de personnes alors je crois
qu'il y en a encore certaines qui sont
présentes mais en tout cas il
avec les statuts et avec les assemblées
générales qui se font ils essayent en
tout cas aujourd'hui d'être à la hauteur
des espérances du ministère
qui a évidemment avait mis un coup de
pression il y a trois ans suite à mon à
mon témoignage et il faut rester par
contre effectivement très très vigilant
et surtout au niveau du comité éthique
dans lequel j'ai été élu au mois de juin
et vérifier bien tout ce qui se passe
aussi sur le terrain et je vais m'y
atteler et je vais je suis en contact
avec eux pour aller dans les clubs
essayer de continuer à détecter parce
qu'il y a encore évidemment des
problèmes aussi bien des problèmes
de violence psychologique parce que ça
existe beaucoup et c'est très difficile
c'est aussi difficile c'est pas
comparable aux violences sexuelles mais
c'est je veux dire ça ne doit pas
arriver donc je suis en place moi en
tout cas au sein du comité équipe
éthique pour aller sur le terrain et
pour aller essayer de détecter les
violences psychologiques ou
éventuellement des choses un peu plus
graves et ils sont en pleine
restructuration alors c'est pareil ils
ont ils ont 30 ans de retard puisque la
gouvernance l'ancienne gouvernance a
duré plus de 20 ans donc bah il faut
reprendre tout en main et ça prend du
temps et ça peut pas se faire en
quelques mois
mais en tout cas j'y suis très vigilante
et j'ai un pied maintenant effectivement
avec le comité éthique et ma propre
fédération
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres questions dans
la salle
non c'est bon donc sachez que
si vous souhaitez compléter vos
informations comme je vous l'ai dit
précédemment à l'oral ou à l'écrit avec
grand plaisir revenez vers nous sinon
j'ai une dernière question à vous poser
et ce que vous pensez nous avoir tout
dit
en fonction de votre de vos questions je
pense avoir répondu à la plupart des
questions en étant voilà France honnête
et bienveillante là comme ça non mais
peut-être que des choses peuvent me
revenir et qu'on et qu'on puisse en
parler mais en tout cas aujourd'hui
voilà le constat que je fais
que je fais je vois quand même que les
choses avancent mais faut rester très
vigilant et il faut toujours essayer de
contrôler avant je n'avais
malheureusement pas
l'accès à ma propre pour parler de ma
fédération ma propre fédération
française des sports de la classe j'ai
un accès via le comité éthique ce qui me
ce qui me permet de suivre très près les
dossiers les affaires en cours et
surtout d'aller sur le terrain parce que
je crois vraiment quand on quand on est
une assiette une ancienne athlète de
haut niveau et une ancienne victime il y
a pas mieux que d'aller sur le terrain
pour essayer de détecter des problèmes
psychologiques ou d'autres ordres donc
c'est vraiment ça fait partie de de mon
combat de continuer à être sur le
terrain sur la glace et de détecter les
problèmes qui puissent arriver et de
recevoir la parole bien sûr
est-ce que vous avez autre chose à nous
rajouter avant de laisser la parole une
question de Claudia Rouault
donc est-ce que vous avez autre chose à
nous à rajouter parce que vous venez je
vous ai posé la question si vous aviez
autre chose et par rapport aux questions
peut-être qu'il y a une question qu'on a
oublié un sujet que sur lequel vous
souhaitiez aussi
nous faire des annonces ou nous aborder
un thème qu'on a oublié
regarde juste sur
mon petit cahier parce que j'avais
préparé un petit peu
[Musique]
non les sensibilisations que je fais on
en a parlé
de contrôle de nos habilités aussi des
éducateurs des bénévoles ainsi que les
sanctions à l'encontre des dirigeants
qui n'agissaient pas à l'époque et bien
avec cette loi on a avancé aussi on
espère qu'elle soit votée à l'Assemblée
nationale
dans quelques mois non je pense que j'ai
on a vu quand même beaucoup de beaucoup
de points je vois pas ce que je pourrais
rajouter là
comme ça est-ce que vous connaissez
quand même et ce que vous pouvez nous
signaler les signaux qui détectent qui
soit en tout cas détectable par des
parents
qui expriment un malaise d'un enfant ou
un mal-être
c'est une très très bonne question et je
vous en remercie alors les les mal-être
ça va être échec scolaire ça va être un
sportif qui ne gagne plus de compétition
ou qui ne progressent plus d'un coup ça
peut être l'anorexie ça peut être la
boulimie en fait ce sont des
comportements où l'enfant va avoir un
problème soudain qui pourrait alerter
alerter un parent me concernant par
exemple et ben au bout de deux trois
mois d'agression j'allais en compétition
je faisais quatre chutes par programme
ce qui m'était absolument jamais arrivé
par exemple bah ça c'était un appel au
secours c'était que je tenais plus doux
et que j'y arrivais plus sur d'autres
athlètes j'ai remarqué c'était un échec
scolaire sur d'autres c'était il
répondait à leurs parents d'un coup ils
ne supportait plus que leurs parents
leur disent quoi que ce soit ils se
rebellait donc voilà ce sont des signaux
ça très très important que les parents
droits doivent prendre en compte très
vite
une question
dans le cadre enfin vous êtes une femme
de terrain justement dans le cadre des
personnes qui qui vous interpellent sur
des alors là on va sur des violences
sexuelles vous êtes il arrivait et
combien de fois de d'inviter la personne
à porter plainte contre son club ça fait
des rations une personne et de
l'accompagner d'ailleurs auprès des de
la police ou de la gendarmerie pour
l'aider dans cette démarche
alors on a des lors de témoignages comme
ça on a des personnes en place avec
d'autres associations qui nous aident
aussi vis-à-vis des victimes
il y a une victime notamment qui avait
vécu la même chose que moi dans le même
sport que moi juste avant etc puis aller
à la police et moi je lui ai proposé
évidemment de venir avec elle mais elle
m'a dit non je dois y aller toute seule
je je veux passer cette étape là toute
seule donc ça dépend en fait des
de la victime de ce qu'elle ressent mais
en règle générale soit on a à faire un
psychologue qui peut la conduire soit
nous on les dirige on les oriente mais
moi directement je n'ai pas
j'ai proposé d'aider pour porter plainte
et ou alors de le voir un psychologue ou
un psychiatre d'abord c'est à dire que
je propose un panel de solutions pour
les aider mais je n'ai pas accompagné
une victime à un commissariat pour le
moment ou un psychologue voilà en tout
cas ça ne m'est pas encore arrivé
par contre avoir la suite des dossiers
avec la personne qui était allée porter
plainte qui avait eu un procès bien sûr
que elle m'a téléphoné elle m'a tenu
informée elle m'a dit voilà grâce à toi
j'ai réussi à parler j'ai réussi à aller
à la police sans toi j'y serai jamais
arrivé c'est grâce à ton combat à ta
force voilà ce genre de témoignage bien
sûr que je l'ai souvent et d'avoir ce
résultat là aussi c'est une c'est une
victoire pour moi puisque j'ai aidé la
victime à aller au bout de sa démarche
après aller à la police porter plainte
c'est pas forcément
la victime qui va se sentir mieux parce
qu'elle a porté plainte ça dépend de son
niveau
dans lequel elle est actuellement depuis
combien de temps elle a été agressée
qu'elle est sa situation familiale etc
etc donc il y a pas mal de choses à
prendre en compte par rapport à une
victime dont on reçoit la parole
monsieur gayege a été écarté est-ce que
vous attendiez à ça ou est-ce que vous
attendiez aussi cette position où est-ce
que vous êtes
déçu et que vous attendiez autre chose
alors m'attendais absolument pas à ça
parce que encore une fois mon livre
c'était ma dernière chance d'être
entendu et et je ne savais pas que ça
allait prendre ses proportions là à la
fois médiatique et que le ministère
allait prendre ça en main et que ça
allait faire tout ce chamboulement que
ça a donné donc non je ne m'y attendais
pas
je pense que c'est une bonne chose qu'il
ait été écartée et que la ministre des
Sports effectivement
après les choses en main et et
encore une fois c'était pas c'était pas
facile bon il a il a démissionné c'est
pas il a pas été
congédié il a il a démissionné et je
pense qu'effectivement c'est une
restructuration et de la part de cette
nouvelle fédération il y a eu 30 ans
malheureusement de de plein de plein de
choses qui sont passées
terribles sur plein de points de vue
différents et qu'il est temps
effectivement que les choses soient
mises à plat et de recommencer à zéro
donc oui je vais pas dire le contraire
je pense que c'est une bonne chose mais
que là il faut continuer à écarter cette
personne de notre fédération qui était
omniprésente encore il y a quelques mois
mais est-ce que ça vous suffit
ça me suffit c'est déjà une bonne chose
maintenant effectivement il faut pas
parce qu'il est sorti par la porte qui
reviennent par la fenêtre et voilà c'est
tout est là c'est à dire que il faut
vraiment l'écarter de cette fédération
il était encore présent il y a
omniprésent il y a quelques mois donc
il faut il faut être très vigilant pour
ne pas que qui soit
omniprésent et que c'est c'est
ses amis ou des personnes qui ont
soutenu
ce président soit encore au niveau de la
Fédération il faut il faut restructurer
cette fédération et avoir vraiment un
renouveau total
sur cette fédération
oui effectivement la question de
l'entre-soi et du non renouvellement
des équipes c'est quelque chose qui a
beaucoup été évoqué qui est beaucoup
venu d'ailleurs qui traverse l'ensemble
des fédérations du moment sportif de
manière générale moi je voudrais vous
interroger sur un autre aspect parce
qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
l'accompagnement des victimes et en fait
nous on aimerait aussi entendre
peut-être des propositions sur comment
éviter le fait qu'on ait des victimes à
accompagner et donc comment mettre fin
justement aux agressions qui ont lieu
aujourd'hui au sein de ces fédérations
mouvements clubs par exemple ce matin
sur la Fédération de tennis il a été
évoqué le fait que jusqu'à très
récemment il était normal qu'à mon
traîneur prenne une chambre d'hôtel avec
une jeune sportive lors de compétition
et que c'était quelque chose auquel il
souhaitait mettre fin et que oui ça
nécessitait de prendre deux chambres
d'hôtel au lieu d'une mais que c'est des
moyens qu'il faut mettre pour éviter
justement les agressions
est-ce que vous avez peut-être d'autres
propositions à faire spécifiques aux
patinage ou peut-être
commun à d'autres fédérations
par rapport à la chambre d'hôtel
effectivement on doit pas dormir avec
son entraîneur donc il y a même pas de
question à poser il faut il faut deux
chambres ça c'est clair et par rapport à
l'idée d'avoir un double entraîneur qui
se déplace en compétition ou qui ou qui
qui est vraiment présent
à chaque fois sur les entraînements
hors glass sur le terrain ça va selon le
sport en fait sur le terrain ou en
dehors je pense que ça c'est une idée
qui peut être qui peut être vraiment
je pense que ça peut vraiment aider
d'avoir un entraîneur homme et femme ça
je pense que c'est quelque chose
vraiment il faudrait qu'on arrive je
sais que c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup
d'argent encore une fois d'avoir un
double entraîneur sur un sur des
compétitions ou sur des déplacements ou
dans les clubs mais parce que et puis
aussi il y a pas que les hommes il y a
aussi des femmes qui agressent
aussi alors le pourcentage est minime
mais si on arrive à avoir vraiment ce
double entraîneur je pense que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui peut qui peut
sauver
certains prédateurs et certains athlètes
ça vraiment je pense que c'est vraiment
une idée à creuser et à peut-être imposé
oui peut-être une autre question aussi
parce que
on nous a beaucoup été remontés le fait
que même lorsqu'il y avait des enquêtes
administratives y compris d'ailleurs
avec la cellule du ministère
qui a été faite le la personne mise en
cause n'était pas forcément écartée
par rapport à la victime ou même par
rapport au club ou à la
traîne et ce que là-dessus vous voyez
peut-être une proposition même si on
entend bien la difficulté étant donné
que on garde la présomption d'innocence
et qu'il est très difficile parfois de
pouvoir avancer là-dessus est-ce que
peut-être vous avez une proposition
là-dessus parce que ça aussi c'est
beaucoup venu le fait d'être de garder
des athlètes parfois des mineurs en lien
avec un entraîneur un coach qui est mis
en cause dans une affaire
alors là c'est c'est vrai que c'est
très compliqué c'est une très bonne
question on a eu des entraîneurs
malheureusement qui qui ont été
nous pour notre part dans notre
discipline qui ont été écartées six mois
mais malheureusement comme il y a cette
prescription et que ça faisait plus de
30 ans que c'était arrivé et que c'était
la parole contre la parole de l'autre et
qu'il n'y avait pas de preuve
cet entraîneur là qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce que fait le président du club
si il n'y a rien contre cette entraîneur
d'officiel en fait qu'est-ce qui peut
faire alors bah soit il le réintègre
parce qu'il a pas le choix comment
est-ce qu'il peut le mettre de côté s'il
n'y a pas eu
d'erreurs de fautes annoncée en fait du
pénal ou c'est ça tout le problème c'est
qu'il y a eu des entraîneurs qui ont été
réintégrés pas par faute de preuves et à
cause de cette prescription sur le
nombre d'années alors je me mets à la
place d'un président de club comment je
fais chez une personne en face qui a été
voilà pendant 6 mois écartés qu'est-ce
que je fais comment je fais pour le
pour ne plus qu'il travaille dans mon
club alors si il travaille plus dans le
mien et qu'on fait une voilà une
convention ensemble pour qu'il ne
travaille plus intelligemment peut-être
qu'il va proposer ses services dans un
autre club et dans ce cas là il devient
dangereux aussi pour un autre club donc
là effectivement je ne sais pas je ne
saurais pas répondre à cette question
mais c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
c'est très très important et c'est une
très très bonne question et je ne
saurais pas y répondre ce n'est pas je
n'ai pas je sais pas je n'ai pas les
éléments
Sarah bol merci merci à vous merci de
votre disponibilité de votre sincérité
vous êtes livré et c'est ce qu'on
souhaitait vous donner aussi de votre
vécu et un petit peu de vous parce que
nous c'est ce qu'on recherche dans nos
auditions aussi c'est de pouvoir faire
des pouvoir écouter pouvoir entendre au
pouvoir discuter et pouvoir aussi faire
des propositions aussi qui protègent nos
jeunes sportifs d'un univers qui devrait
être beaucoup plus serein qu'il l'est
merci et à bientôt et vous n'hésite pas
vous n'hésitez pas à revenir vers nous
pour toutes les différentes informations
bien sûr que vous souhaitez nous
apporter par la suite
avec plaisir merci à vous pour cette
initiative bonne soirée à vous
merci beaucoup